[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
court is back in session for johnny depp
and amber hurd i am talking about the
difference between a punch
which johnny did often
and me having to hit him in my defense
whiteheard says she got physical with
death and heard reveals why she filed
for divorce i've been so scared that it
was going to end
really badly
for me
plus i don't think that's funny period
that's disgusting hurt addresses the
infamous incident where feces was found
in depp's bed and later this individual
came here
with the ex
expressed purpose
of taking as many black lives as he
possibly could what led up to multiple
mass shootings across the united states
last weekend law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman amber heard
spends the entire day on the witness
stand answering questions about her
relationship with johnny depp there was
one incident depp considered was the
last straw in the marriage involving
feces and his bed law and crime's
angelina levy is here with amber heard's
side of the story
johnny depp had testified that he found
out from one of his bodyguards that the
housekeeper had found feces in his side
of the bed who those feces belonged to
and how they got into the bed that's a
major point of contention in this case
you may recall bodyguard's starling
jenkins testified that amber heard took
responsibility for the feces in the bed
he said heard described it as quote a
practical joke gone bad or wrong but on
the stand heard said that depp's dog boo
a four-pound teacup yorkie was
responsible for the defecation in the
bed and she explained why
what if any issues did boo have with
bathroom problems if you will she had
eaten
johnny's weed when she was a puppy
and had a bowel control issues for her
entire life among some other issues she
was you know we regularly had to take
her to the vet to try to figure out
well what was wrong with this dog never
met a dog that
was quite like this um so she had some
control issues
hence uh why we would she liked to
burrow in the bed she liked to be in the
you know by the foot of the bed
underneath the covers and
it was um
customary that they slept in bed with us
but boo
having the issues she had we have to
leave her in bed so that she wouldn't be
encouraged to to go to the bathroom um
which would happen almost immediately
once you put her down on the floor and
sometimes it happened in bed too why
would that not be something you would do
first of all i don't think that's funny
i don't know what
a grown woman
does i i
was not also in a pranking mood i had my
life was
falling apart i was
at a crossroads in my life that was
really
serious and i had just been attacked on
my 30th birthday
by my violent husband with whom i was
desperately in love
and knew i needed to leave
it was uh not really a jovial time
and i don't think that's funny period
that's disgusting depp had testified
that when he saw that photograph of the
feces in the bed that he actually
laughed because it was so grotesque and
ridiculous he said it was at that point
and then after his mother passed away
that he decided to divorce amber hurd
but amber heard said the decision to
file for divorce was actually hers so
it's a major he said she said for law
and crime daily i'm angenette levy in
fairfax county virginia
thanks angenet joining us today is
co-host terry austin an entertainment
lawyer mitra ahrian mitra herd seemed a
little more polished on the stand than
she did when she testified days ago is
that helping or hurting her case
you know it's absolutely noticeable she
had over a week to
get polished as you said you know to get
more prepared to
be more ready with her answers and the
way she presents her answers to address
the jury if you notice she specifically
turns and addresses the jury anytime
she's answering
and then goes back and addresses
opposing counsel and so she's much more
prepared and a lot more prepared to
handle some of the tough questions that
are coming at you
coming at her
yeah we'll see how those those questions
keep going because you know what's
coming next cross-examination terry so
now we get to listen to heard side of
the story let's call it uh poop gate now
i don't have a tea cup yorkie but i've
got a doberman and there's a big
difference between
human feces and dog feces especially
teacup yorkie what are your thoughts on
this species issue
well there are definitely two sides of
that story depp obviously is claiming
that his security team called him and
said look there's a picture here and
basically she's admitted that she did
this practical joke but now she's
claiming that her dog who
basically did accidentally
poop on the bed and so it is definitely
a he said she said and i think the fact
that she previously admitted it to one
of his team one of depp's team means
basically that she did it and so i think
the jury is probably thinking he's
making up excuses here that it was the
dog and the main issue is the size of
the
disposable poop on the bed is probably
something that is a really big signal
here that it wasn't
a small dog so yeah we'll see what the
dirt leaves at the end of the day yeah
if there's just one dog owner on that
jury i think they're gonna know the
difference between a teacup yorkie and a
human being and that might come back to
uh for lack of a better term bite her in
the backside later on thank you both
still ahead on lawn crime daily amber
heard's testimony continues in the
defamation trial against ex-husband
johnny depp
ahead we'll show you video heard
recorded of death and hear why she says
she hit her then husband
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're taking a closer look now at amber
heard direct examination on monday
jurors listened to an audio recording of
a fight between depp and heard and which
hurt admit to getting physical with depp
after the recording played she told
jurors she had to retaliate physically
i know when you have a closed fist
you're not hit i'm sorry i hit you like
this but i did not punch you i did not
deck you
motion of my actual hand was but you're
fine i did not hurt you i did not punch
you i was hitting you how are your toes
what am i supposed to do do this oh
[Applause]
because you start physical fights
i did start a physical yeah you did so i
had to get out of there yes you did so
you did the right thing the big thing
the you know what you are admirable
every single time what what's your
excuse when there's not a physical fight
then what's the excuse that
you're still being admirable right just
by
running away
amber please explain to the jury what's
transpiring in that audio recording what
that's about
well there's
there's two different
there's two different situations that
we're referencing in this fight two
different altercations between johnny
and i involved in the door
the first of which which we first start
talking about
where i'm talking about hitting him i'm
talking about
what that conversation is about is about
the disparity
uh of this the disparity between johnny
and i in our physical fights the
disparity of
how he would proactively punch me
and i would have to resort to reactively
hitting him
i am talking about the difference
between a punch
which johnny did often
and me having to hit him in my defense
i know the difference between those two
and i'm highlighting the difference
between those two even if he wasn't
twice my size they're very different and
that's what i'm pointing out to him
later jurors were shown a video
recording taken by herd in which depp
can be seen slamming cupboards in the
paris kitchen
what happened
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
were you in here
no absolutely nothing happened to you
this morning yeah you're right i just
woke up and you were so sweet
we're not even fighting this morning all
i did was say sorry did something happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
no that's the thing you want to see
[Music]
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this morning oh you got this guy
you got this going
oh really
really
terry from herd's testimony it was
unclear when the domestic violence or
alleged domestic violence
began and how many times it occurred do
you think she clarified that to the jury
well it's very interesting she talks
about the fact that there's domestic
violence happening all of the time he's
either hitting her or punching her or
choking her or pulling her hair out but
the very first question that they asked
this morning on the direct to finish up
the direct was to clarify one of the
discrepancies and that discrepancy was
when was the first act of physical
violence it makes me wonder whether or
not they had some conversations but i
have to trust that she did not have a
conversation with her lawyer because
she's been instructed not to do that but
she clarified that that first act with
winona ryan the tattoos that was the big
act she originally said that it was in
2013 and then she clarified it was in
2012. and then she went back and tried
to clarify some of the dates and she
tried to explain why in the uk there
were 17 incidents and with the tro there
was only a few but listen the jury is
basically trying to figure out how many
times there was domestic violence and
what is really truthful yeah now metro
we saw there heard's attorneys walking
her through this audio where she admits
to hitting death but it's weird it's
like she has a different definition for
punch and hit uh depending on size or
maybe gender and then try to say it
self-defense did that make sense to you
i don't think that there's a way to make
that recording sound good whether it's a
punch or a hit or whatever the case was
it within the context that we are
hearing it without the context she's
giving us it sounds like she's the
aggressor and there's really no way
around that when you're listening to it
so her attempt to sort of explain away
why this was happening and why it was
important that it was a hit instead of a
punch i think is going to fall on deaf
ears yeah
especially from the audience like you're
saying comparing the two
we'll see how it continues in the case
though coming up on law and crime daily
our coverage of the johnny depp amber
her defamation trial continues we take a
closer look at amber heard's testimony
why she says she filed for divorce from
death
[Music]
welcome back testimony delve deeper into
the final days in the relationship of
amber heard and johnny depp on monday
heard told jurors why she filed for
divorce in 2016.
i knew if i didn't
that i knew if i did not likely not
literally survive
i've been
i'm so scared that it was gonna end
really badly
for me
and i am
i really didn't want to leave him
i loved him
so much
i wouldn't have done anything but i
couldn't
i couldn't do that one thing i couldn't
stay
the promise and the hope that i had i
had become less and less regular and
more and more rare the monster had been
this thing that was now the normal and
not the exception
the violence was now normal and not the
exception and
it was um so
so hard
it was so hard but i knew i had to do it
i believe he would have
taken it too far
i wouldn't be here
terry there have been multiple
objections in this case on both sides
one side seems to be uh doing better
than the other though uh can you walk us
through the basics though
listen when you do a trial there are
certain objections that you're going to
hear all the time and we've heard it
here whether or not the question is
leading whether or not it's based on
speculation that's not going to be
something that's going to be introduced
whether or not it lacks a foundation so
the person has to have personal
knowledge to get that in and that has to
be established you've heard the
objection of non-responsive because
people go on and on and they're not
responding hearsay is also the biggest
one here it's an out of court statement
asserted to prove the truth of the
matter so you've heard that objection
but we've also heard listen judge it's
not for the truth of the matter and
there are 23 exceptions under the
federal rules and so some of these
objections are you know that it's not
offered for the truth of the matter or
it's an excited utterance so there are a
lot of reasons to object and you have to
balance whether or not you have a right
to object or whether or not it looks
like you're trying to hide something a
difficult balance yeah eight years as a
public defender maybe almost 4 000 cases
first time i've ever seen someone object
to their own question that's that's a
new one for me now mitra how does her's
explanation of why she filed for divorce
fit with this claim claim of defamation
well if that's the reason you know if
this all this that she said that
happened really happened then consistent
with that it would make sense that she
would file for divorce and want to leave
him
the problem is that we also have johnny
saying that he was the one that wanted
wanted to divorce amber so there's again
more he said she said yeah it's gonna
come down to who do they believe i think
it's gonna come down a lot based on the
cross-examination because i think that's
where the truth really comes of amber
heard and johnny depp and we'll leave it
up to the jury for that but to keep up
with the gavel of gavel coverage of the
johnny depp versus amber heard trial
make sure to follow our newest podcast
lawn crime sidebar listen in as some of
law and crime's top hosts recap the
highs and lows of the trial so far
straight from the fairfax county
courthouse in virginia subscribe on
apple podcast or online at lawncrime.com
when we come back a weekend of gun
violence across the country the details
of several mass shootings that left
multiple people killed and more than a
dozen injured
[Music]
welcome back more than a dozen people
are dead and many more others wounded
following several mass shootings across
the country over the weekend in
milwaukee 17 people were left injured
after a shooting friday night blocks
from the arena where an nba playoff game
happened hours earlier there were no
fatalities and all the victims are
expected to survive in total 10 people
were arrested in connection to the
shooting and in california one person is
dead five others injured and a man is in
jail following another shooting at a
church sunday police say they have not
determined any motive but the attack was
on a group of asian churchgoers members
of the congregation stopped the suspect
themselves by hog tying him with
electrical cords
also on sunday two people were killed
and three others were hurt in a shooting
in houston texas at a flea market
sheriff's deputies say a group of men
got into an argument when they pulled
their guns on each other and started
shooting
and authorities in buffalo new york are
trying to piece together what led up to
a mass shooting which left 10 people
dead and several others injured at a
top's grocery store saturday officials
arrested 18-year-old peyton grayton
after they say he carried out a racist
attack as the incident is being
investigated as a hate crime state and
local authorities held a press
conference sunday to thank those who
quickly responded
i want to thank
law enforcement at every level federal
state
buffalo police erie county sheriff's
department for their tremendous response
the buffalo police responded in less
than two minutes
after this incident began
i want to say a special word of thanks
to
the buffalo police officers because if
not for their swift response and
courageous actions more lives probably
would have been lost yesterday that is
important to note this individual came
here
with the ex
expressed purpose
of taking as many black lives as he
possibly could
another shooting in north carolina left
seven people wounded officials say there
were shootings at three separate
locations and that they were all related
no one's injuries are life-threatening
mitra other than the obvious are there
things that connect these shootings that
may have helped prevent or even reduce
the loss of life and injuries in these
tragic shootings
well surely any time i hear of a mass
shooting i think of mental illness
because it really does take somebody who
has mental issues to be able to carry
out a crime of this nature to kill
multiple people as if they're not even
human beings
and i think that you know when i think
of that i wonder okay where were the
signs did no one observe anything that
indicated that that these people would
do something like this and
in buffalo you know the shooter there
there were signs he was hospitalized but
then he was released and so that may
just makes me wonder
where is our system failing in terms of
identifying the people that will
uh
inflicted these kinds of crimes on
society thanks absolutely not only with
mental health but also when we identify
these people how are they getting guns
in their hands terry hate crime charges
are likely to be dropped on the shooter
in buffalo should we expect federal end
state charges in this case
oh i'm expecting both state and federal
charges in this case the state's
definitely going to bring some murder
charges as far as this is concerned just
because it was such a heinous crime and
the justice department already announced
today that they are investigating this
matter as a hate crime meaning that it
was a racially motivated crime and they
said they're going to do a thorough
investigation and they have the
resources do exactly that and based on
reports that we've heard so far brian it
does seem as though there will be plenty
of evidence they've already stated that
there is online social media evidence
that this could very well be a hate
crime so i expect we'll see charges
later down the line absolutely my
thoughts go out to the families affected
and i'm looking for some solutions from
our representatives thank you for those
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you